welcome to the
recruitment roller coaster podcast my
name's hisham azuz
today i'm joined by ephraim stevenson
who is based over in melbourne australia
has worked in the recruiting industry
for coming up to 19 years
in that time has successfully built six
recruitment businesses
in 2019 he actually exited five of the
recruitment brands
he was involved in and for the last year
uh ephraim has been building
uh a business called koner and co which
is an executive search firm
across 10 different verticals ephraim
welcome to the podcast thank you very
much
good to be here um so obviously as i
just said efrain's over in melbourne
who obviously unfortunately has been
putting locked down of the last 48 hours
and um look there may be some connection
issues that shouldn't but bear with and
i'm confident that we'll have a really
good conversation
um but where i always like to to start
and where i always like to
to sort of um start this conversation
ephraim is how
how did you end up in the world of
recruitment let's start there
thanks a good question mate um yeah i
guess like a lot of
english backpackers i've never worked in
recruitment before
i came across to australia in 2001
and my first job was actually working on
the sydney harbour bridge doing the
bridge clients
and um from there basically i got a job
in uh which was advertising sales and
my boss at the time made a couple of
phone calls and i ended up getting my
first gig in recruitment which was
actually a telemarketer it's an
appointment setter
for a company called atomic consulting
and um
basically i was being paid 13.50 an hour
um they were going to give me one
percent of everything that i build
revenue-wise and
i did that for about two weeks and it
was appointment setting for probably
their consultants to
to go out and potentially bring the work
back in long story short was they were
coming back and saying that it wasn't
really
gelling or that the leads weren't warm
enough um i begged to disa
and approach the directors and asked me
if they were willing to give me a go
doing recruitment um the old saying well
at that time it was
uh puey commission only and um yeah
luckily for me i kind of fell into
construction um my background
my family's in construction um and from
there basically you know i was a top
builder from the first month
um for the i guess the 20 months that i
was there until i actually went out on
my own set up my own business i was
i was 24 when i got into recruitment and
at 26 when i set up my own agency
okay why why do you think
you was able to hit the ground running
i think at the time hayes um there was a
a recruiter called luke
clinton who was hazy's i guess number
one
construction recruiter property
recruiter and very dominant within the
the sydney market and
look there was just a real niche there
and ultimately you know property
construction
um there was a number of roles obviously
become that were becoming available
across
multiple sectors um and it actually gave
me a free-for-all really to pick and
choose which clients i wanted to recruit
for which industries i wanted to recruit
for
um you know that backed with as i
mentioned obviously you know my dad was
in construction granddad was
in construction so it comes from three
generations of builders
and you know the old scene goes in
recruitment you've got to be you know
you've got to be passionate about what
you do and what you're recruiting for
and fortunately for me it kind of just
stuck you know and
whether or not i'd say recruitment is in
my dna but
i each sleep breeds recruitment so yeah
okay
all right um let's just just quickly
because
i mean what what did the australian
recruitment landscape look like in uh
2001 compared to obviously now what what
yeah well i guess if you look back to
to that time and you know 2000 through
2004 was pretty much when
most of the the mid-sized boutiques kind
of came to you know came to fruition
you know the likes of now careers
launching over in australia
you know the guys obviously design and
build um
you know obviously launched a similar
time to designing construct which was my
agency
he had constructive recruitment so there
was all these kind of medium-sized
specialist agencies popping up and there
was there was actually plenty of work
for all that to go around
um and i guess at the time
you know for the first three years of
the business everything was smooth
sailing we uh doubled our revenue
revenue year and year out um and then
obviously
we decided obviously to double it double
the size of the business
and then the gfc kind of came around and
hit but yet ultimately
there was so much opportunity out there
and speaking to clients
um recruitment is obviously a
relationship-based business
and back then then to say hey he's
definitely had the majority of the
the lion's share so it was actually
quite easy to go in and
negotiate obviously better rates than
what hayes were um obviously charging
and yeah really kind of dominate that
market so
just yeah okay interesting all right so
let's just
unpack this ephraim i want to make sure
that sort of we give good context here
because
you're clearly someone that's um i mean
yeah you've been involved in different
businesses and these types of things i
just want to make sure
so we sort of understand the journey so
so for the last year you've been
focusing on conor and co right so we'll
get to that
but before that obviously the majority
of your time in this industry has been
obviously yeah when you set up your own
agency which you said the first
what was that design and construct you
said right that's it yeah
yeah and then so just quickly then so
and that was over a
15-year period right that's correct
but within that time you started four
other recruitment businesses
i did mate yeah so i'll take you back
literally right back to the beginning so
started my basically my career in
recruitment commission only
and did that for two years as i say if
they
the company i was working for would just
grow too quickly too soon and
the commission only model just wasn't a
viable model for them or any business i
guess
long term and if they had been paying my
commission on time and i've probably
still been there i was on a very good
wicket i was very well looked after
um but the reality was that when i
joined the business they had about five
staff when i left there about 25 i had
seven direct reports
uh coming into me the construction
property arm was actually their largest
revenue
uh stream so obviously when i left um
there was no
i had no employment contracts had no
restriction of trade
which is kind of unh which is kind of
unheard of in the industry
um but at the end of the day at the time
we were living in the city
in sydney cbd and obviously there's a
lot of distractions in the cbd as
um as any recruiter would obviously know
so we actually kind of moved to
the middle of nowhere um where no
distractions i set up a home office
um so one shareholder one director and
you know for the first 12 months it
really was
sweet sailings had a number of clients
um obviously reached out to me
had a very successful first year and
then decided to get my first office
um so basically moved back into sydney
cbd
got an office there took on my first
employee um
he was actually still with the designing
construct brand which is now building
careers
he's been with the business for about 30
years and 13 14 years so
um from there basically went from two
i actually had an additional four
consultants who made quite a big leap
uh from two to six and kind of wrote
that out for about two or three years
you know business was going well but
then i mentioned earlier the global
financial crisis came around
i just got engaged and i just bought a
house and uh you know stress levels were
through the roof
and we unfortunately had to let
basically three of the team go so
we're back down to three rode that out
really for about
probably for about two years um and then
he should think of a saga that was
just a huge success story for me
personally but also for the business
in the space of four years i took design
and construct from a small office
in north sydney um to sydney melbourne
brisbane perth london um we
had a total head count uh back in 2019
when i exited around about 50
52 consultants across basically the five
offices
um and it was really it was really rapid
growth so we went from
six um up to 12 doubled again then which
is doubled again
up to 24 and then consolidated for about
six or eight months
um and then literally i was just
constantly on the road
and interviewing consultants opening up
to the new offices
um trying to get the brand out there as
much as possible
and look there is there's definitely ups
and downs with that um
i think being one shareholder one
director and
where a lot of my competitors actually
had multiple directors
um kind of liking the load shall we say
it was certainly
obviously challenging a learning curve
for me personally and professionally
and not coming from a recruitment
background and one of one of my biggest
regrets i guess made is
you know i was self-trained with you the
agents just started with it there's a
phone
there's a desk crack on you know but you
do
do whatever you could do to generate
some revenue and
um you know because of that i guess
ultimately
um he put me in really good stead
for actually running my own business and
my background from the uk obviously i
was born in england
um moved to jordan at quite a young age
again my dad was in construction lived
in jordan for about four and a half
years
then back to the uk and then we moved to
south africa for four years
um and then back to the uk again they
moved out here when i was 24.
and so i've actually now lived in
australia longer than i've actually
lived
um i guess in the in the uk but my
background in the uk my first
my first professional job was actually
working for axa insurance
and i was doing outbound sales for them
um you know so
that combined with which was my next job
which was newspaper sales account
management account exec
um going around visiting clients
face-to-face meetings
and so that combined with the axa
experience when it came to recruitment
it was just like a perfect perfect match
the outbound sales obviously you know
the client interaction candidate
interaction from a
you know from an interview point you do
and it's something that i just
absolutely fell in love with and you
know as i've said to you before i really
do
eat sleep breathe recruitments um so
even obviously now in my new venture
i'm on the phones now i'm recruiting i'm
obviously doing deals
and that's that's the part that i love
and ultimately i guess we design and
construct
when we got to the size of five offices
i kind of missed that i missed that
start
let's wait wait wait let's unpack this
right two secs
lesson that's cool now one of you so
that that's really helped right
so everyone will now know what went on
so the reason why i just stopped you
there is because
a lot of people one of the most common
things that people ask me from
recruiters recruitment business owners
in the in the uk 80 of the uk
recruitment market
um is sub 10 staff okay around that
different sources or whatever right
so why just stopped you there is because
i just i just wanted to sort of hone in
and focus on
maybe some key milestones some key
breakthroughs for you personally
that enabled you to break through those
glass ceilings because i know when we
spoke
you said that um yeah that like you you
had some
sort of pretty breakthrough moments when
you started doing things a bit
differently
in terms of scaling right yeah so uh
let's just so so the first thing that i
just wanted to um
ask you that that is that's relevant to
today
um the global financial crisis
yep what as a business owner what
what did you learn during that period
that you think applies today
yeah look that's a really good question
i think ultimately it comes down to
yeah again it's a cliche but you're only
as good as your last placement
and i think but given design and
constructs
tracked track history with clients and
the way that we you know
present our candidates the the process
that we went through
we were always very thorough in our
approach and you know our candidate
synopsis
outlined you know candidates skills
experience attributes availability
salary expectations um you know why
they've left the most recent role but
ultimately why we think as consultants
they're suitable for our clientele
and i think because of all the hard work
we're putting into
the actual process of sourcing the
candidates
interviewing them getting them across to
our clients that backed with a 12-month
replacement guarantee which at the time
was completely unique in the industry
nobody was offering that
and that combined was just a really
useful tool for
when things did start to you know the
wheels did start to wobble a little bit
during the gfc
and then they completely fell off and it
was all those relationships that we
built up in that short space of time
where clients
you know as an organization 95
of our revenue was a repeat business um
you know i know
i would always say to the consultants
you know work smarter as opposed to
working harder
you know if we can really get into the
other organizations where we can
actually make a difference
and we can educate them in regards to
what the recruitment process is
the amount of work that goes in behind
the scenes to actually source candidates
um you know whether it's from our own
crm whether it's from our own network
you know whether it's from advertising
or whatever the case may be
it was our clients always kept coming
back to us and i think that's testament
to
building a brand which is obviously
something that you're really big on
and to me personally you know designing
constructs
and i'm gonna be biased mate but uh i'm
sure a couple of you listeners or a
couple of people you may know in
australia
it was arguably like at one of the most
solid
construction property recruitment brands
on the market you know we were
constantly coming up
against organizations like i guess
design and build
um you know the constructives of the
world but now careers of the world but
they
all had probably 20 years recruiting
experience on me
and so it was very flattering to be able
to build a brand where people
genuinely enjoyed coming to work um
and i think you know some of the the
milestones for me or what was a real
shift for me um i'm i'm dyslexic you
know my highest
graded school was a d and that was for
drama and so the actual operational side
of running a business isn't necessarily
my forte and one of my biggest
achievements was when i actually first
hired my operations manager
in sydney which then allowed me to when
did you do that
that would have been in 2000 uh probably
just as we literally started to grow
again so it would have been
2009 2010.
um and then really from there it was
just the case of
ramping up so we've got the operations
manager in place
we've then got all the systems the
program oh yes let's just talk about
that because i think
this is this has become a really common
effort conversations that i've had with
recruitment business owners recruiting
entrepreneurs who have successfully
scaled their business
there's always these sort of key moments
where
we bring it back to process or we bring
it back to
sort of the the people that i've been
speaking to recognizing and having the
humility to go you know what that isn't
my forte but it's important i need to
get someone in to really manage that and
do that process right
which is what you started talking about
so just just quickly
um and i'm sure this evolved and you
worked this out but
like what was the intention when you was
thinking about this operations person
what
in your head what was your thinking
right if i can get them to do this this
this and this it's going to enable me to
free up my time to do the things that
i'm better at so what was the sort of
core um
processes or core things that they were
gonna sort of take over for you just
just to spell that out because i think
that would be really helpful for people
yeah not a problem so i guess gfc
as a business we were predominantly 80
per
20 temp going into the gfc and
you know in hindsight obviously we
should have probably got that mixture a
lot better
but what i decided to do was certainly
coming out the coming out of the other
side of the gfc was making sure
that we had a large template like that
that was basically the number one
priority for me to be able to do that
though
we really wanted to make sure that we
could streamline the whole process
so do away with all the paper trail do
basically bring in the best tech stack
that
money could buy for us to be able to
give the consultant
the opportunity for speed to market and
that's my strength in regards to you
know business development account
management
you know mentoring teams growing high
performing teams but the operational
side
is definitely something that you know
was my weakness and
fortunately for me there was a lady who
i hired
and called cheryl um sunderland who is
now called
cheryl bolanos long story short she
actually contacted me
for an operations manager role and her
salary was just way above what i could
actually afford to pay
for that position at that time we kept
in conversation
and you know about two or three months
later cheryl actually came back to me
and said look i'm i just want to work in
your business
i'm happy to basically start whatever um
but i really
i buy into you buying to the ethos of
the company and what you're looking to
achieve
everything that you're looking to set up
i can do pretty much straight away for
you so
we actually hired cheryl and she was the
first instrumental hire
really for the business from a
management point of view um
you know and also for me as a business
owner and i come up against this and
have this conversation
a lot of the time it's being able to let
go of the reins
being able to i guess provide somebody
else with the
i guess the management opportunity in
your organization to actually run things
and you know why is that difficult do
you think why was that difficult
i i think it's risky you know and a lot
of people think it's you know
it's a very incessant industry um
there's a lot of intellectual property
that obviously
come with a recruitment agency and i
think everyone's always
mindful of you know if somebody's gonna
come and join the organization
you know they potentially learn all the
the tips tricks
advice and again the systems and
processes and potentially obviously take
that away
that was certainly my my hesitation at
the time anyway
um you know in hindsight i should have
probably brought in an operations
manager or someone in a similar type of
elk a lot earlier
and what helped you get over that then
well what helped me get over that i
guess was the the desire to grow
and expand you know i was all about
world domination i really was you know i
was
obviously you know my late 20s going
into early 30s and
like it was just the the passion that i
have of growing a business
um it's quite contagious and even myself
i get myself out of bed every morning
and with the the end goal of wanting to
achieve something i wanted to basically
make something better
um you know brand is a real big thing
for me at the time
designing constructs when we had five
employees probably had one of the
best brands on the marketplace i had a
full-time graphic designer working with
me from day one
um you know which is pretty much unheard
of in the industry certainly back then
but that graphic designer was worth his
weight in gold you know from a brand
awareness
from a strategy um from a market
basically um presentation like we were
from the outside looking in we looked
like one of the largest recruitment
agencies in australia and i think that's
what's so important about
marketing digital marketing about
branding and but also about believing in
your actual product and believing in
what you're actually doing
um you know there's a number of brands
out there in the marketplace
that unfortunately just haven't had the
investment or the time or the energy
pumped into them
and that's something designing construct
for me something i'm very proud of
we won you know three years in a row
linkedin's more socially engaged
agencies um we won 2017 the best
training
through the recruitment international
awards um for best training initiative
in the whole of australasia
yeah it's those types of things that
really give me the buzz and
and again really you know and take me
back to why i got into recruitment in
the first place
so so so um so got the operations
manager and she joined you
like what what was what was i guess what
were some of the maybe one or two things
that you made you think [ __ ] out why
did i not do this earlier like what were
the sort of key
um things that she she did that really
had an impact on you being able to scale
your your recruitment business
well i guess literally just taking away
every
administration or operational type of
responsibility or task
um you know we were implementing
obviously back then where it implemented
bullhorn so there was a lot of
integration that needed to come with
that
and then obviously all the marketplace
partners to bullhorn as well
but you know one thing when i when i
actually hired cheryl
i actually hired somebody and somebody
called simon who
previously had run his own business and
he actually had a very successful
tent business and brw fast started three
four years in a row
and unfortunately had a falling out with
his business partner and
approached me to see whether there was
an opportunity for him to come on board
with design and construct as i said at
the time we weren't doing a huge amount
of temp
um and that was his forte and again
another turning part
the point in the um i guess the
successor designing construct was
actually setting up that contracting
division
and actually having somebody like simon
lead that from the front
and you know that wasn't my forte again
i'd never really done temp
as a recruiter to a certain extent um
but yeah no that was definitely
a turning point for us as a business
operations manager
somebody running the trades and labor
side of the business or the contracting
side of the business
again then to free up my time to go to
market to actually try and attract and
obviously hire the best individuals in
the market is that what you ended up
focusing on then after you got those
sort of people in place
absolutely that was purely i guess my
ultimately my goal was always
prospecting
you know always speaking to people um
basically
of all different walks of life and i
think you know one thing for me i come
from a very humble beginning mate
um you know lived on obviously housing
commission or council estates or
whatever you want to call it so for me
personally i always treat everyone as
they expect to be treated and i think
that kind of moral has got me so far in
life and certainly so far in recruitment
um you know i can tell you numerous
stories in regards to
i've just made a placement about three
weeks ago um
by talking to a co-founder of a very
successful tech stack company
and who i met walking my dog you know
it's those
it's those types of opportunities which
again give me the buzz
and really get me out of bed in the
morning because it's every every day in
recruitment is completely different not
one day is the same
um and and again it's just going back to
the early days in designing construct
it was it was that buzz it was that um
you know that high energy high
performing team
that that really got um that really got
me going
so so obviously had way more time to
yeah as you said prospects grow the
business
yeah i guess but then also but but then
also but then also look at technology as
well mate and
you know so without the assistance of i
guess the technology that we implemented
and again
given the size of the business that we
we were we were one of the largest
advertisers and all the major job boards
in australia
brand was very prominent technology-wise
you know we were using bullhorn
um from bullhorn we also integrated some
of their marketplace partners
um you know so you had daxtra
technologies which was in essence
basically there
an additional search technology within
bullhorn we were using
cube19 and also inside squared which is
big data analytics
at the same time we also basically saw
i've started to work one-on-one with a
guy called mike walmsley um
who you may or may not know from the uk
but ultimately mike
is to me personally he's actually one of
one of the mentors that's got me as far
as i think i have in my career he's
um he was a wealth of knowledge a wealth
of wisdom we started doing one-on-one
video conferencing uh calls and how did
you how did you
how did you engage in that by the way
how did that happen
yeah well i guess mate i i've always
um you know i've always wanted to
surround myself with business coaches
and and basically just individuals that
are really i can learn from that i can
absorb their information or their
knowledge from and i just found mike to
be
really open and and really forthcoming
with his experience
and also his material so his training
material his marketing material
um and me personally i always want to
develop my skill set develop my team
uh training for me as a business is
actually you know it's really high up
down that's on the list of priorities
we can create basically one of the best
working environments for anyone to come
into
but if you're not up skilling your staff
and training your stuff you're going to
get
left behind you know so mike and i
basically put together a structured
training program
for each member of the team and we were
doing one-on-ones we were also doing
group training sessions
um mike again as i say has got a wealth
of obviously um
knowledge and experience but also
marketing material and training guides
and that we basically we're speaking to
mike in regards to a recruitment
excellence guide
which we put together in essence it's
about 300-page
recruitment guide that could teach
anyone how to recruit from a resourcer
but he's also got relevant content in
there all the way through
a recruiter's career so resource a
recruitment consultant principal
consultant etc
we implemented that and straight away
like we noticed a huge
um conv the conversion rates were just
going through the roof so we knew we
were on to something we knew the
training was working we knew the
approach and basically by structuring
everyone's day not micromanaging but
structuring and giving the information
in regards to
taking more of a detailed job
description you know asking more
relevant questions
at a client visit cross-selling at a
client visit
and you know it really it really turned
the business around and at that time we
were doing about 700 000
turnover and then the time i was working
with mike on the one-on-one and also the
training
uh with the learning management system
so we got up into
over a ten million dollar business so if
we what
happened then though was you know you
can only recruiters are
are interesting characters aren't we you
know we're always basically we're always
craving for more so it didn't matter to
me personally how much training i was
giving the team
um you know certain team members would
really get engaged in it
and then others would find it though
it's not really for me so it's i guess
about finding that fine balance in
regards to how you can keep everyone
motivated engaged
but also show them that that ultimately
the training is actually going to
benefit them not
not just profess professionally but also
financially
and we then you know why do you think
why do you think all of that has such a
dramatic impact on profits
well i think that implement that
alongside the tech stack that we had
and the back office support from an
operations it was just
all everyone needed to do at that time i
think yeah at that time i had about five
or six consultants who had previously
run their own recruitment agencies
working for me
and you know a lot of them actually
still i've actually got one guy who have
hide four times now he's actually coming
on board as a partner with me
in august and i think you know
those those individuals had all worked
for the likes of hazes
you know you at the time you're julie
ross's you know your robert walters
and you know coming aboard to a small
boutique which we were
but giving all this technology at their
fingertips you know like things like
lucia
you know obviously which everyone's
using now we were using like 10 10 years
ago or the equivalent of
and and and again just investing heavily
into the best tech so
bullhorn worked wonders bullhorn really
enables enabled us
to onboard our candidates board
basically the consultants as quickly as
possible
and from there also what we then did as
i say the daxter
implementation also helped us speak to
market
it was a lot a lot detailed search
within bullhorn
the big data analytics that cube19
provided us and then also
inside squared provided us with tangible
data
where we could really track everybody in
the business not micromanaging but track
their
basically activity so no activity we're
also able to track
all their internal interviews because we
can sorry candidates
and also track the consultants basically
client meetings you know what were the
conversion rates
we were then able to collate all that
data and really work out
sweet spots in regards to okay jobs
to interviews interviews to client
interviews and then obviously
to placements and it just worked and we
came up with a mod
basically a i guess a module which was
if we pick up
five or each consultant picks up five
solid jobs
every single week from those basically
five jobs if you can
send out ten candidate synopsis and then
the synopsis is what i was talking about
before
outline skills experience attributes
availability salary expectations reason
why they've left the most recent role
but ultimately
why myself or our consultants would
think they're suitable for the role
yeah it's that um it's that i guess by
doing that we were then able to really
basically track those ten candidate
synopsis if they're getting anywhere
close to two to one ratio
five interviews then the deal's going to
come so five jobs ten candidates had
oxage five interviews with clients
and the one placement it was actually
greg savage uh one of his master classes
that i picked that up from but
it just it just worked and yeah
everybody really got the
science behind it and the process
absolutely absolutely everyone would
have the small little white boards
basically in front of them you know and
they would have to have the metrics
basically bringing up there
and we were tracking it all and reported
on a daily basis weekly basis to all
consultants and providing them with that
information
the good thing with key 19 as well was
obviously the leaderboard
um yeah i think we were one of the first
companies to actually sign up to cube19
when they first launched out here and
again that had a huge impact on our
business the leaderboard very
competitive
we had five offices you know to so to
actually have everyone
you know basically accountable and
there's nowhere to hide with that type
of stuff right ultimately
you know it's a revenue based role but
when you've got a leaderboard that's
constantly changing in real time
i i actually found that that was also a
real turning point for us because it
kind of get that
you've got that camaraderie but you also
obviously need the i guess the sales
kind of environment as well and that
certainly helped us really manage that
and showcase
um we were probably one of arguably one
of the best players in the industry
and one of the best commission
structures on the market we
rewarded hard work we give additional
incentives
additional bonuses if people were you
know exceeding the targets it's
basically you know how do we reward that
so
again implementing champions lunches
implementing basically you know
obviously top builders um every month
every quarter
um was really constantly trying to
strive and
make sure that consultants really did
sit on the morals of the laurel
ultimately constantly had that kind of
carrot to you know
encourage them to obviously go out to
market to really capitalize on
their chosen sector but also bring
never forgetting that it's all about
quality over quantity right
and and you know we would always be
checking synopsis so the managers in the
business would always be checking their
consultants and offices to make sure
that is of that high standard that we
expected because
those synopsis were really you know
testament to our
interview process but also the the
methodical approach that we actually
took
through it we it was very rarely we
actually had candidates fall off i mean
we were offering a 12-month replacement
guarantee
and you know and people at the time
thought we were mad but the reality of
it is
again as i mentioned obviously the
amount of repeat business that we had
we very rarely replace candidates
because it's all about i guess the
understanding the job brief and again
that this was all the implementation
that we got from
the likes of mike hormsey you know
obviously listening to likes of greg
savage
and really kind of just making sure that
we have the best technology
or the best systems available now
another thing that we were the first
company in
in which he in bullhorns history we um
partnered with kayla partners and so
raymond penny over there
absolutely terrific guy if there's any
bullhorn customers looking for some
additional support i can highly
recommend kylo partners
and we were the first company to
implement docusign into bullhorn
um you know and again it's exciting the
business that we were
we were being pioneers in our industry
and and nobody else was doing that
so again if you look at the crm with the
big data analytics on top of that you've
got the best search engine technology
within the
within the database at the time then
linkedin also became the first crm
to migrate or basically to work in
conjunction with linkedin
so they actually had the linkedin
integration it literally meant my team
had
nothing else to do but working bullhorn
and yeah and again
we each sleep breathe recruitment we
also eat sleep breathe bullhorn i'm a
big advocate of bullhorn
i can honestly say that i i put a lot of
success down to
the way bullhorn allowed us to actually
set up the business properly put the
foundations in place
from an operations point of view but
then also
make sure that everything was being
tracked and everyone was accountable for
what they did
um you know it's from a website point of
view we were constantly updating the
website
every every 12 months we would have a
brand new design on the website
still the same brand but ultimately you
know websites change right and obviously
you know the industry's changed
um we were ranked google one page one
ranking
organically you know for over 500
keywords basically we had over 500
landing pages on the site
which were all specifically written by
you know companies that we'd obviously
outsource
to they were obviously writing white
pages we were doing salary surveys
again nobody back then was doing
anything like this um
and that's really something that we've
kind of brought across into all the
businesses
and but especially in tacoma and co
we're able now to kind of
everything that i've learned over the
last 18 19 20 years
um combined basically with the business
experience of the startups of the
scaling of the exiting
and then also you know going through the
ups and downs it hasn't all been sweep
you know obviously it hasn't been an
easy ride
going through a gfc you know obviously
trying to find the right investor
and you know obviously going through the
process of scaling up a business
and you know the uk was probably one of
the most challenging
um offices for me so so um so look then
so
to make that super simple then
operations manager
tech stack training development
processes were all sort of
the the sort of key parts of the recipe
that rich rich
and and reaching out to key individuals
oh yeah and then yeah constantly
reaching out to key individuals that
could
help sort of take your business further
when did you
so when did you start seriously thinking
about exiting this business then
and why how did that come about yeah
well
there was a number of reasons behind
that mate um
personal reasons i guess obviously i've
been in a relationship and married for
15 years and
basically decided that obviously we're
if that wasn't going to continue so
at the time um we went through basically
divorce went through a separation and
obviously a settlement
and at the time basically you know
recruitment has
always been as i say in my blood but the
design and construct brand got to the
size that it did
and it's not that i i didn't enjoy the
obviously the five boxes what i didn't
enjoy was all the travel
and i was constantly traveling from
office to office to office and
where i where i got that wrong
personally is
um again by not releasing or giving away
the reins to other people in the
business
earlier and feeling as if i needed to be
you know
in control running that i guess the
whole business i mean at the time when i
exited it i actually had quite a quite a
large operations team so i had
an operations manager who's been with me
for about six years
um we had a financial controller we had
a dedicated payroll manager
we had a dedicated accounts receivable
we had a digital marketing
uh specialist we also had a trainer
basically a full-time trainer
um and that's literally just within kind
of the ops team or the back office team
and and because the business was kind of
self-sufficient and it was running
itself
what what really got me going was when i
actually brought the investor in my role
was to actually go to market
and try and identify other businesses
that we could actually bring under the
under the advance um
what i what i actually did was there was
a lady called leslie delimi who was
hazel's global villa
for six years out of eight um and
you know she was doing about 3.2 million
gross profit her last financial year
with hayes
and we approached her basically to come
over into the business
um and we managed to sign leslie bring
her into the business straight away
i think her business now is doing about
50 million turnover in 18 months
and you know it's it's those types of
opportunities
that that i love focusing on and i guess
that's where the other businesses
also came from is really my network in
the in the industry
um speaking to other like-minded
entrepreneurs they've obviously seen the
success with designing constructs
seeing the success basically a couple of
other agencies and i think that's what's
now falling through to the canaan
co-brand is obviously
people reaching out who are keen to
actually now go out on their own but
um you know a little bit uncertain as to
you know how they do that financially
whether it's the capital whether it's
the systems process procedures
and to me that that's the easy part of
setting up an agency
um so sorry just quickly so how
how how did it actually go out then what
was it a management buyout
was it a private equity deal how did you
actually exit the
your business so it was actually
basically a private private investor
and basically bought me out of the three
businesses
so basically it was design and construct
which is now rebranded to building
careers australia
preston james and also 420 consulting
and the design and construct limited was
sold to a separate investor
and they've now rebranded to ingenie
resources
and they're arguably going to be
probably one of the biggest engineer
recruiters
um how did you source these investors
yeah so i guess the investor um was
actually bizarre enough he was actually
my old
neighbor in my first office he actually
said it was for you know you met him
your dog well i would have met him in
the list at some point
that's how the conversation would have
started um started the relationship
there i guess
his business he was in property
development and a number of other things
he then went on to um yeah basically to
become a director of a large engineering
consultancy i kept in contact with him
my financial controller previously
worked for this guy
and obviously i knew with him he um he
made a couple of inquiries
a few years prior so up until literally
2017
designing construct was fully funded and
all the attempts basically all
everything to do with the business i was
funding it myself it was only once we
got to i guess
over to the uk and we were doing quite a
bit of contracting over there that's
when i was looking for that investment
or that capital to really take the
business to the next level
and look it's testament that it's
happened you know i think the business
will probably be doing about 60 70
million
turnover and in conjunction with
obviously you know
i guess the trades and labor or the
mining side of the business now
and and the timing for me personally was
just right for me to exit basically
rather than obviously keep holding a
couple of businesses i wanted to have a
clean
clean slate um you know i knew basically
they were going to be in good hands or
certainly as far as i was concerned but
um yeah i guess the opportunity then
obviously arose from me too so
so was it so just quickly because look i
think
a lot of people have had that sort of
vision of building and selling a
recruitment business right which is why
i'm just asking obviously questions
about
it but so yeah so obviously for what you
wanted personally you wanted to clean
slate you wanted to get completely out
so was it just a matter or so did you
not have to stay on for any period after
that was that not part of the deal
was that they just sort of you yeah you
agreed on a settlement that you was
happy for and then you
walked away and there's no
responsibilities to hit certain metrics
or whatever after
yeah so i get guess with um two of the
businesses it was just complete buyout
and there was no restriction just a
complete buyout
the building careers business was
obviously initially a buyout so in
regards to buying into the business
and so i sold 60 equity um to
to the investor and also somebody who'd
been with me for a few years started as
a recruitment consultant
then into a principal then into a team
leader
and then basically into a state manager
role um
we brought him to the table made him a
director of the business as well with
the intention of him growing and running
the
kind of designing construct building
career side and i'll continue on the
acquisitions
it transpired about nine months in that
obviously they were hemorrhaging going
through money with obviously all the
um acquisitions and there was an equity
call made
and quite frankly made obviously i built
this business up over 15 and a half
years
um and i just didn't agree with the
equity call that's the reason basically
ultimately why building careers so
design and construct why
exit to do that and that's why i
basically decided to make a clean slate
and
i was once i actually exited completely
um
the plan was was for me to take 12
months off as i say how did you feel
how did you feel let's just talk about
how did ephraim feel after
15 years blood sweat and tears as you
said one of your biggest
pitfalls has been letting go you've now
to let go of the whole bloody thing
no more no more yeah i mean no more
going around his offices whatever like
how did you
like how did you actually feel after
after exiting those businesses
yeah but to be honest with me it was it
was actually
it was a relief um given the amount of
i guess the the amount of work that was
going in
um to me personally as you know from a
professional development point of view
um at that time i joined the ypo which
is a young president's organization
i'd already been approached by a couple
of other companies as well to to
actually do something with those
um and also a couple of my own
investment opportunities as well
i just felt that the timing was right i
didn't obviously
the the alignment with the investor
didn't wasn't working for me and i just
felt it was the right time for me to
exit
and really stay and again start afresh
you know after 15 and a half years
going through obviously going through a
divorce going through a settlement as
well
i felt as if i'd taken design and
construct as far as it could as it could
go
they then basically rebrand under the
building careers
um basically business model and that was
really then to go out and obviously
i guess to tackle other industries and
other markets
and that again wasn't in line with
really where i saw
ultimately myself going my area
specialization
is in startups it's in property
construction it's in recruitment to
recruitment
it's in ic software um and and again it
just doesn't align with my
with my personal values so what do you
so what did you do in those 12 months
then
it well five weeks inmate i was at we
went to bali initially
um where i got engaged and then my uh my
fathering will actually invite us across
to hawaii so myself and my wife were
across in hawaii
this is five weeks into a what was
supposed to be a 12-month sabbatical
and i was bored i was bored shitless
mate um
why is that why well i guess ultimately
i missed recruitment
um i missed the buzz of recruitment and
i just missed the phone ringing
um i missed basically getting up in the
morning and obviously just
planning my day speaking to candidates i
love changing
people's lives you know in recruitment
you really do make a difference and you
know you can
really change somebody's life for the
better but you could also obviously you
know potentially
uh do obviously do some damage as well
if you don't do the recruit obviously
don't do the process right
um and it was i was literally just
sitting there and
um and i just i was speaking to my wife
and i said look
i think obviously i'm gonna have to do
something else and we were talking about
business names and conan co and kona is
actually
on the big island in hawaii um and
that's where the name originated from
but as soon as i got that into my head
conor and coco and co
you know within the first three months
of me launching cobra and co
we were profitable from month one um we
were absolutely smashing goals goals
month three
um come month six um
i got a letter from the investor and
from the management team
at my old business um basically along
the lines of i've come out the traps too
fast
and uh if i could quietly obviously just
batten down the hatches and and
really not recruit for anything to do
with property construction
or or any or anything that i recruited
for historically
um so that kind of put a bit of a
spanner in the works and the brakes on
in regards to the growth of kodanko but
after obviously dealing with that for a
couple of months that's now
all been taken care of and now obviously
we're kind of back to the growth
obviously rapid growth
quick expansion um obviously
market domination we've now got four
offices in kona and co
sydney melbourne uh brisbane perth
london's also there as well uh but
obviously account that's a separate
country we're looking at expanding into
singapore into hong kong
and also into americas um we're now a
head count of
12 um which has obviously grown rapidly
over the last couple of months with
further hires coming on board
and it's that it's that growth it's that
brand it's
you know you look at the colon co brand
um
on linkedin on our website it's very
prominent
as i mentioned to you previously we've
actually got 10 revenue streams the
business has been set up as a
partnership model
so myself ultimately as the founder but
we do have managing partners in each of
the 10 revenue streams
with the growth strategies to have four
partners underneath those
one in each state and then from there we
would have the associate partners
and then basically the principal
recruitment consultants underneath them
what's the benefit of that model the
benefit of that model
ultimately for me is again from a
management point of view
um but also to attract the right level
of caliber of obviously talents and
consultants
um you know we've we've got a structure
in place where it's very black and white
anyone who comes on board as a recruiter
resourcer um you know has a target
basically where they own 30
of everything they built over target 60
grand a quarter
and is their target but once they build
half a million dollars for the business
they automatically get a promotion
the target stays exactly the same but
the commission is actually bumped up to
40
and they would then go into an associate
partner role
once they actually built 100 sorry once
they built a million for the business
they then get the opportunity to move
into a partner role with equity actually
offered at that stage
um so the business model we've got a
growth plan and strategy in place to be
at 50 partners by 2022
which we're already well and truly ahead
of basically
our time frame as to where we wanted to
be the covid absolutely has set us back
there's no ifs or buts of that
um but i guess we're learning to pivot
we're still obviously on boarding we're
still taking people
into the business and into the team um
and
the the actual model that i've created
and gone to market with
has been so well received and you know
that we're literally
all the last two weeks all i've been
doing is literally speaking to you know
recruitment consultants
division managers state managers
directors founders of recruitment
agencies
who are actually you know really
interested in coming on board with the
knowing co brand
you know it's given obviously what's
going on with the coverage situation
there's a lot of doom and gloom in the
market um you know and
not that we're we're doing anything
different to anybody else but
ultimately you know we're making
placements we're picking up jobs
you know we're hiring we're growing we
you know
we've got the best tech stack on the
marketplace and it really it's just a
it's a good it's a good feel good story
um
and again the the interest that we're
getting is is actually really flattering
if i'm on this tradition
so just as we sort of come to the end
here then what
what were sort of the key things that
you had in mind when you decided after
five weeks you're going to start another
recruitment business
um that you obviously learned from your
15 or so years experience
that you was like right obviously we're
starting conor mcgregor i'm going to
make sure i do this this and this
because
what i've learned in the last 15 years
um has taught me that so what were just
some of the
key parts that you had in your mind that
you really wanted that was sort of
non-negotiable when when starting kona
and code that came from
your learning experience did you think
yeah
do you know what mate i'll go back to
the question and i'll answer that in a
second i'll
go back to the question you asked how
did i feel when i exited the businesses
and there was like there was something
missing that i couldn't explain
what it was and but it's honestly
recruitment yeah absolutely mate like
i'm glad she's sitting there and
tweeting with my phone is going okay
what
i'm used to managing multiple offices
multiple businesses
now all of a sudden literally i've got
obviously yes i've got a very bright
future ahead of me i'm 40
at the time i was 41 years old um you
know
just weighed up basically where i'm
going to go now with what i'm going to
do next
um you know at the time we just
basically purchased a cosmetic business
and my partner has a cosmetic business
i was like okay well i could get
involved in this to a certain extent but
um
recruitment's definitely in my blood um
it's that that
really was the driving force behind
comrade co and then
what a fan was made once i started i
just couldn't stop
like it was going to be ultimately
the actual business itself was going to
be more of a lifestyle business i had
that many clients that many candidates
that i could work with
you know just take it easy work you know
part-time hours whatever the case may be
and if any if anyone that
people that do know me knows that once
um yeah obviously recruiting mate
i do 15 16 hours every single day i'm up
at four o'clock every day
and that's what conor and co has
basically provided me again it is
actually that passion
that drive that motivation and to change
people's lives but also to create
arguably one of the best brands in the
marketplace and that's ultimately what
i'm striving towards not retiring
anytime soon then
not retiring any questions no and yeah
there's so many opportunities out there
mate we've obviously got the comanco
um brand in regards to recruitment but
i've also got kona and co capital as
well
where in essence basically it's a seed
fund for startup agencies
um where we're currently speaking to a
dozen um
potential obviously individuals that are
going to come on board under the conan
co
capital brand will actually provide them
basically with everything they need to
set up their own agency
um knowing full well they've got the
full support and back office support
of everyone obviously within the
business and that in itself is created
like so many opportunities
um and so many conversations for
individuals who
typically speaking mate six months ago
probably wouldn't be willing to have
these conversations
but i think the whole coverage situation
and you know with everyone working from
home it has become a bit of a luxury
um and people are enjoying working from
home and working part-time hours so
i think the recruitment industry is
definitely going to change um
and how do you how do you how do you
what do you
think the sort of feature might look
like in australia well maybe
it's disrupt or be disrupted do that
ultimately that that's
i guess what we're trying to drive
towards is we want to constantly be
changing evolving pioneering
in recruitment you know there's so many
new tech technologies that are coming to
market
and you know companies like referee and
you know organizations
and like inside recruiting there's so
many new tech or add-ons to the
recruitment
game that can really add so much value
not just to you as a consultant but
obviously to your brand and your
integrity
and i think because we're always you
know willing to
look at new technology try new
technology if it's going to make a
difference to our business
it's going to help we speak to market
it's not going to dilute
the brand or basically the consistency
of the quality that we expect
then we're all for that and i think
having um
you know obviously a very flat
management structure that is open to
change
and you know really embraces technology
i think that in itself is such a huge
usp for our business for people wanting
to join
you know um the recruitment training
that we provide to our staff
is second to none you know the
recruitment training and hr side of
comrade co
we offer on every single placement free
access basically to our
lms we offer a copy of the recruitment
excellence guide you know that's
probably about three thousand dollars
nobody's offering usps like that in in
the australian market
and and that's really why we you know
from a recruitment training hr
piece you know as a business owner i've
spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
on recruitment on recruitment for
recruitment
and and you made some phenomenal hires
but it was always the training and
basically the follow-through and you
know the chatting with those consultants
um that really i guess where the the
industry kind of dropped
um you know so being so passionate about
recruitment i want to do something
different i want to give clients the
opportunity
of getting more value for the money and
also you know with the guarantees
extended guarantees
and which i think is just a given in
this market right and if you're not
willing to
obviously you know work with clients
long term and you're not able to help
them out during a difficult
spot or whatever the case may be it's um
yeah you're going to struggle in
business and
and again the jobs that we're get we've
got coming through now
are all relationships so they're all
relationship driven
um you know and somebody i've got a
client at the moment i've placed over
100
full-time employees with this business
and i've recruited for them for
over 18 19 years and you know i've
recently just become an ambassador for
exo works um and basically you know
they've got over 2
000 consultants globally their ceo i
recruited for
18 years ago we haven't spoken in 18
years but called me out the blue because
basically she was looking for an
executive search provider in australia
and i think it's to have those types of
clients come back to you after such a
long time
you know you're doing something right
yeah so
love your energy love your passion
clearly definitely uh
eat live sleep
recruiters recruitment business owners
would take on your advice said listen
um they'd implement your advice tomorrow
it could be a word or phrase or sentence
wherever it may be what what do you want
to what what what your partner was to to
the
people and the recruitment industry
you know the old saying goes we spend
too much of our time at work for us not
to be happy
and for me personally it's about
creating
that work-life balance for everyone in
your team and treating
everyone in the business as an equal we
find
too often in recruitment that the
accounts operations team becomes
separate to the sales team and it's it's
so common right
it's about making sure that the whole
team is embraced one of my biggest tips
i
i would give to anyone is in a start-up
mode
brand integrity is everything if you if
you can find a
graphic designer and a an ad agency that
can work with you
to really make sure that your brand
awareness and your style guide and that
consistency with the brand
um is key it will just help basically
your business excel
points it's a no-brainer
designing construct we were getting on
average between three and five
brand new client ringings on average
every single day
and that was from all the marketing
we're doing from all the seo that we're
doing and all the brand that we're doing
ephraim it's been a pleasure thank you
thank you appreciate it mate all the
best